you roasted the Boston cops we talked
about this once but what kind of
audience Boston cops
yeah I'm just imagining a whole sea of
them and you're doing comedy about them
and make kind of giving them a hard time
how'd that go over terrible they are
they're a very tough crowd and you know
being from New England Boston the the
they're very skeptical and they're very
tough and I eventually stuck with it and
won them over and it's a cool show Jeff
Ross Rose cops you can see me I also did
a show in a jail of inmates and I open
with the same joke in front of the
criminals as I did with the cops which
was where my murder is at and each
audience three guys raised yeah you even
did I give you points for this in front
of a Albaugh a crowd of all Boston cops
you did a Tom Brady joke I did and he is
a saint in Boston you can't you can't
tell a Tom Brady joke in Boston I tried
cops have a lot of discretion you know
and I said if Tom Brady were kicking a
puppy down the street would you arrest
him in the cops that I would arrest the
puppy for getting in the way of Tom
Brady's you're from the East Coast
you're from New Jersey they're in New
Jersey are Bay our band is a lot of
these guys are from New Jersey you can
kind of tell by looking at them it's
like you know what Jersey guys we're a
lot of we like to bust chops and stuff
like that you guys look fedorable by the
way no you got to pay extra for that I
love coming on this show Conan you got a
lot of fun it's fun here well you know
we try and keep it light you know Andy's
on antidepressants yeah yeah
a lot of talk about getting out of cults
yeah reality slap it's like you came
here on the real fun night
Jeff Ross presents roast battle to war
of the words you gotta be as exciting
show it's two comics going Mike - Mike
and verbal combat making fun of each
other it's like Fight Club for comics it
airs all weekend on Comedy Central it's
live it's a Comedy Central's first
sporting event it's so cool you're gonna
love this joke
Todd Barry's in the finals oh yeah it's
pretty crazy the show was that the joke
you gotta know Todd Barry
you